laughs
hello everyone welcome to irrational
science the only site on the internet
that does physics everybody else
does math
followed by the most irrational
explanation they can give you
someone put in their horse boot
I guess he's referring to the Horseshoe
yeah we're gonna get into that anyways
today we're going to be doing a little
bit of Extinction The Countdown to
Extinction followed by our science
critic again we're going to follow it
with him because uh it kind of lead us
into the problem with what objective
means as far as science is concerned and
why science is definitely and
unambiguously
objective
and then we're going to have open the
floor up for questions and comments that
people made since last time so let's
begin with our Extinction segment okay
here it is and we're going to start out
with the war in Ukraine
fellow made some comments about that and
I thought uh it'd be nice to put them up
here and here he goes he says China will
win this war and then they will turn
their manufacturing on their own
population whoa just as Napoleon and
Hitler lost their Wars because they
stretched their armies along too many
fronts so too will the West lose this
war as China readies to take Taiwan
North Korea ready to take the
Philippines in Japan and Iran ready to
bomb Saudi Arabia
my God this is why the West will end up
losing this war they are pushing with
Russia Russia will take out Kiev as soon
as the warhawks in Russia get rid of
Putin
the West will do nothing
man I surely sure would love to have
this fellas crystal ball okay there you
see uh big Russia against little Ukraine
took part of their territory there in
the eastern part of Ukraine and they're
fighting not only NATO which is the blue
regions there but also the green regions
which now are blue you could say they're
part of NATO and that includes the
United States which is not on the map
there okay meanwhile Russia is
essentially on its own
okay so that's the situation there and
this fellow can continues and here let
me put this up here give me a second
he says the following he says
um China will take Taiwan and the West
will be able to do nothing about it
their War resources are already
stretched too thin it will happen the
military is against the politicians war
with Russia every single one of their
model shows China will enter and the
West will lose
aha the West has reacted has reached the
end of borrowing and so the system is
crashing and they want to create a New
Britain words to create a new monetary
system and blame Russia for their
default because they have stuffed their
debt
into uh pensions Banks and insurance
institutions
again love to have this guy's crystal
ball
uh my crystal ball says something a
little bit different okay that's all I
can tell you right now but let's move on
here we have a professor at a university
and he says the following okay he went
out in the news the other name says the
U.S support of Ukraine is more than
moral and legal support based on said
article blah blah blah U.S action is
based on self-interest to defeat Putin
to allow NATO expansion and to promote
democracy also we are testing weapons
and equipment our training in our in
their use and the logistics of their
supply our behavior is consistent with
the long-held American strategy of what
forward defense and the promotion of
democracy to me this forward strategy
and promotion of democracy are not
consistent with the development of a new
world order of peace and mutual
Prosperity with China and Russia
well poor Professor Fister got the
mauled in the comments section by a lot
of people when he wrote this article
okay people didn't like it
and what can I tell you you know I you
know we're all born and we're raised and
we're brainwashed
uh to believe in countries we're all
nationalists essentially most of us at
least right the great majority of us
we're uh I guess you could call
territorialists some people say we
inherited that from I guess the days of
the Permian when uh we had the mammal
like reptiles you know like the
Metrodome and so on and you know and
that forsaurus and some of these other
animals and we became territorialists
okay and so when you're born you know
you're born in this country
you're taught the national anthem you
are asked to look at the flag that's
your flag
not the other one that one is is yours
and so we become territorialists and
there's a natural tendency for us
monkeys you know we're social animals
like all the other Apes out there and we
tend to like our group you know and the
other one the group across the river
that's the enemy
you know what I mean and so you so you
know if people are asked to decide or
choose you know one side they usually
choose the side that they're born in the
one that they've been brainwashed in
so we are all in a sense nationalistic
that's what they teach us that's what
most people succumb to okay so we're all
nationalistic but let me put it in the
right context here
uh we have two gangs
we have the South Side we have the north
side gang
Chicago late 1920s
uh which one do you owe your allegiance
to which one would you like to owe your
allegiance to the North side or the
South Side
and it's what I'm talking about here you
have uh Mr Al Capone and boats and Moran
boats Moran ran the
north side
and Al Capone the South Side there you
can see the red and blue region stay
essentially governed right or controlled
to a great extent the uh
violet blue there or uh purple uh that's
uh kind of a No Man's Land There were
bands gangs here that sometimes choke
you know switch sides back and forth but
that's essentially their territory
and so the question is are you gonna
wave your red flag are you going to wave
your blue flag
what side are you gonna choose
it is here and my point here is that you
know it's good not to choose sides in
this war because they're all gangs
that's all it is it's just gang war you
have one gang that wants to overthrow
the other gang and this gang attacked a
certain territory and the other gang you
know decides to defend it it's just
gangs
that's all it is you know you did not
elect a government you did not elect the
politicians politicians are all Not
Elected but selected
they are selected by the rich and
powerful and you get to vote for
whichever one they put in front of you
and so uh it's like you voted for Al
Capone or Bugs Moran you know who do you
like best
okay that's more or less the situation
so what can I tell you
um you're wasting your time if you
choose sides okay
um
the best thing you can do if you can
manage it it's not everybody can manage
it is try to forget about your flag your
national anthem your country and just
look at it objectively what is it to you
how does it affect you personally
you know and that's the best way to look
at it so it's very hard to detach
yourself from all that but that's that's
the ideal that's what you should strive
for it took me a long time to figure
that out that's all I can tell you okay
so here we have Mr Elon Musk some of you
know him okay and this is what he has to
say about China something coming up
which is the uh decline in population in
China okay and he says the following
Elon Musk warns a massive danger looming
over the world China's recent
announcement has the global CEO Gravely
worried must cause population decline a
what massive Danger
okay this drop which could continue
until the end of the century could
severely harm the economy and the
pension system
and you can see there the graph that I
showed last time where you can see the
decline in the birth rate essentially
you know year after year it's coming
down for China
a lot of people say well you know I
don't give a damn about what's going on
in China I mean who cares you know
that's the problem they have over there
I'm over here I'm in a different gang
I'm there I'm in the north side not in
the South Side okay so I don't have to
worry about China right
uh yeah you do have to worry because
there are implications
from these uh events that are happening
on the other side of the universe kind
of you know inside of the world uh we're
all interconnected we live in a very
um interconnected world
uh economically interconnected also
military social and so on but more so
economically we're all economically
interconnected and if China has problems
uh that of such a big country as China
one-fifth of the world population that's
going to have an effect on you
indirectly okay so uh just keep that in
mind and yeah as you can see here uh
there was a note recently China's
population dropped in six decades sounds
alarm on demographic crisis and again
they're saying that China's population
fell and so uh it is a topic that is
lately coming into the news okay so just
be aware of that that does affect you
and you say well who cares about China
after all you know India is still
growing right and it turns out here's
the uh numbers for India okay and you
can see that their population is
declining as well
in other words it's growing but the rate
is falling meaning at some point it's
going to approach zero population growth
and so my crystal ball there says that
they may not reach the end of the
century as it shown there 2095 to uh
2100 right at the end I think uh very
soon we're gonna meet Extinction maybe
not as close as I show there I don't
know I can't tell you my crystal ball is
not that Crystal okay but I think uh
extension is around the corner and India
will not reach that uh the end of the
century No Way
um so that's as far as India population
how about uh it's economics well here's
economics for India yeah I lost it
holding give me a second here
on the other side
one more second there we go
okay it says global economic downturn
has begun to affect India's trade
says the incipient Global recession has
begun to affect India and it goes
through all the problems that India is
having thanks to the global downturn so
not only do we have population growing
at a slower rate ever slower rate in
India but also its economics is being
affected and they have the other fifth
of the world population in their country
okay so these are countries you got to
pay attention to uh do we stop there no
here we have Pakistan okay fifth uh
largest country in the world as far as
population is concerned and you can see
their population is declining as well uh
not declining overall total but the rate
is what's coming down meaning it's it's
getting lower and lower and lower and
lower as time goes by and this leads to
zero population growth how is its uh
economics well terrible Pakistan's
economy grinding to a halt as dollars
dry up okay so we're having problems
over there in Pakistan big country and
it says a shorter shortage of crucial
dollars has left Banks refusing to issue
new letters of credit for importers and
he goes on to say that they're having
problems a lot of stuff that is being
left at the um ports because they don't
have any money to move it
okay so uh all these countries are
having big problems and you might say
well that's over there
but see when you put them all together
they have probably at least half of the
population on Earth
and if they're having problems and you
think that that's not going to affect
you over here
well think again that has to have an
effect on you because it is the fact
that they are buying things and selling
obviously right that is moving to a
global economy around and they don't buy
because they don't have any money or
they have some kind of economic problem
uh you don't sell if you don't sell
guess what's going to happen to the
companies in the region where you live
like Europe or the United States
especially well they're gonna have
problems as well
all these countries need to sell we live
in an interconnected World economically
and if the other side doesn't buy like
China India and Pakistan
we don't sell
and I'll leave you to think about that
see if that rings a bell in your head
here's a list of the most populous
countries in the world and how they're
faring and you can see the yearly change
there the third line you can see how all
of them are relatively low very small
percentages that you see there nothing
like it used to be in the past where you
had double digits now that's no longer
true and the only two countries Nigeria
and Ethiopia are the only countries that
are above too and even those are coming
down
why are they coming down well I've told
you this in the past I don't have any
rings of a bell or entered your head at
this point but they're coming down
because people are moving to the cities
once you live in the cities you cannot
have children it's Pro prohibited it's
forbidden
you're not allowed to have children in
the cities it's it's forbidden by law
you can't have children in the cities
because the culture changes the
economics changes
what you were in the country yeah we
used to have our great grandfathers he
used to have lots of kids half of them
died nobody cared you know you wouldn't
even know the names of the people who of
the kids who died
and those that survived well those
reproduced and they just kept going
that's not the case today case today is
that we live in a service economy a city
economy and
um you know people in the cities cannot
have children you can't have 10 children
in an apartment so this is the problem
and so you have peop countries like
China which said well we're going to
stop this one child per family or two
child per family law
and we're going to allow people to
reproduce as much as they want
and still women basically you know
they're they're not reproducing
even within senates uh countries like
Japan Russia they cannot get their women
to reproduce children
that should make you stop and think
you know I mean they're bribing them to
have children they say no even with
bribes we will not have children
okay maybe one you know just to see what
it looks like like do we need it no we
don't need it but I'd like to see what a
kid looks like you know that's that's
all it is but no more 10 children per
women you know like one per year
that's gone that'll never happen again
okay and yeah that'll lead us to zero
population growth zero population growth
leads to economic problems Economic
Consequences it's not free
okay now we had uh some people they uh
met over here in Davos
and it's the rich and Powerful you know
and they've flew their way to Davos okay
and here you have John Kerry now Gore
they were two of the participants
parallel to that uh you have Greta
thundberg she came here and uh to
Germany and was arrested for uh
picketing I guess a mine she protested
that the mine was being
um re reborn uh to make up for the gas
shortages from Russia
you have people like guy McPherson I
like guy because he cries all the time
you know that the climate change is
going to kill us in fact I think he gave
a date like 2024 2026 something like
that very close to our date uh that
climate is going to kill us all
that's the end of the world because of
climate all these people are climate
change they're missing the boat
completely climate change is not going
to change anything
uh regarding Extinction it has no effect
whatsoever on extinction climate change
is happening yeah it might take 100 200
300 years for all we know
humanity is probably going to die a lot
sooner than that we're not going to last
100 years even
and whatever one percent two percent
three percent change in our climate
temperature higher for example right
it's not going to do anything to wipe
out Humanity it's going to be the
economy so forget about climate but
that's what these people have been
discussing over here in Davos
okay here we have um fellow who says
incest doesn't cause genetic defects
okay that's good to know
and it says it is important to keep in
mind that even for an unrelated couple
there is an approximately two to three
percent chance that their child is born
with a defect birth defect genetic
syndrome or disability that is because
genetic disorders only come from what
environmental factors and gene mutations
which can happen to anyone regardless of
inbreeding
well this fellow um is not uh factoring
uh something else it's not that if you
sleep with your mother you know that the
child that comes out of that Union is
going to come out or anything
like that it doesn't happen like in one
generation to look at this problem you
got to look at what I'm proposing which
is hundreds of thousands of years of
inbreeding that's a little different I'm
saying that you know when you inbreed
for thousands of years that has an
effect
and that's the reason humans today have
very very little genetic diversity okay
which is a fact fact in the sense that
if you go out there and check every
human out there you'll find that we're
all clones essentially you know from a
genetic point of view you know whoever
you sleep with today is your brother or
your sister from a genetic standpoint
okay and here's an example of a very uh
famous example which is Queen Victoria
you know uh all the kings and Emperors
of in of uh Europe in the the
earlier part of the
20th century first world war they were
all descended pretty much from uh Queen
Victoria lots of them were not all of
them but obviously a lot of them were
and so what's the issue the issue is
that you know a couple of them had
problems the famous case of Alex and
Nikki you know in Russia they were
essentially cousins they all they both
descended from Queen Victoria one way or
another and so uh and that's just an
example
but you have another example of the
habsburgs Nebraska in Spain uh Charles
II of Spain okay he was known as the
Bewitched because he was born you know
and he descended from a long line of
Habsburg that intermarry that inbred
right and they all had the famous
Habsburg chin
okay which was ooh you know look him up
and you'll find out since the kings of
Spain
um uh Isabel and Ferdinand since that
time all the Phillips they were all
hamburgs and they all married within the
family and so you know finally you end
up in the 1700s with Charles II and he
was important right and that's when
Spain went down to trade really in in
Charles II's reign uh you you'll find
other cases and the other famous cases
the case of the Amish I bring it up
constantly you know the Amish have been
inbreeding for the last 350 400 years in
the states Pennsylvania Ohio that region
you know and today they're having
problems they're having genetic problems
and it's not uh just by sheer coins
tonight this guy says it's um
Environmental
no no we've had uh people who are born
with these problems hundreds of years
ago as I showed in one of those pictures
there you saw these girls from the 1700s
they were born by the hip
uh you know uh Siamese twins
and hopefully the environment did not
was not so polluted in those days to
make them look like that
you know that was a genetic disorder the
beginnings and in fact it happened
earlier I think uh we already had cases
in the 1200s as far as I could trace it
back where uh where they are already
started having genetic problems so you
know genetics has nothing to do with the
environment or if anything very little
to do with the environment or with what
you eat it's got to do with the fact
that we've been inbreeding for so long I
think if you would have come uh if you
could try uh you know travel in time as
they call it in general relativity fifty
thousand a hundred thousand years ago I
don't think you would have found so many
cases as we find today okay
proportionally
okay one fellows us everything is tied
to a cycle okay these people are
cyclical they believe in Cycles they
think history repeats itself the economy
collapses in a cyclic fashion made worse
by government interventions and we
survive okay thank God
we survive in spite of government he
says there was no money in the 1930s
during the economic collapse and what
did people do they created local script
meaning local currency right money is a
tool we will not be so quick to throw it
out just because the economy turns sour
and people don't seem to understand what
what I'm telling them is that people
will not voluntarily
get rid of money is that money will
cease to have value and people will
recognize it as that and nobody will
accept it therefore if you have lots of
money in your hand you will not be able
to give it up because nobody will accept
it
okay because you can't do anything with
it and this person said well we'll
create local script
meaning
um essentially we're going to do
bartering and whether you use some
currency is irrelevant you can use some
currency Monopoly money if you want no
problem do some exchanges with Monopoly
money no problem as long as everybody
gives the Monopoly money value we're
okay you can trade gold if you want uh
or go back to the Stone Age you know
where we used to weigh uh what is barley
and paying with so many pounds of bardi
or salt or whatever no problem you you
can you can agree to have any currency
you want what is the problem
the problem is what I see in all these
movies these end of the world movies one
that comes to Maya's Water World which I
saw
and uh this fellow goes to a fort
and hear the people say okay here we are
and what no one ever says in any of
these films is where does the food
come from who is producing the food who
is Distributing the food that keeps
everyone in the movie alive
food is what the issue is and no one
even touches that subject at all it's
like you know we go to the Future and we
find that after World War one that three
or whatever World War four we have all
these people living in whatever
situation they're they're in
and who produces the food how does food
grow where are we getting the food
and it's like people pay very little
attention to food because you know say
well with food I can get at the
supermarket I just go one or two blocks
away and and there's food all the food I
want I can get potatoes onions whatever
I want
yeah right now
but if there is a World War
all that collapses
no one produces the food and distributes
it especially to the cities
you would have to go to the country and
if you go to the country what you'll
find is factories that manufacturer that
you know processed food and they're not
processing food because everybody's laid
off
and you go to the farm and you don't
find anyone there because it was all
companies that ran all the Farms most of
it at least and they're not working
either so who produces the food
he said well I'll produce my own food
well for city folks first of all you
know that's already a No-No I mean you
can't plant potatoes on your carpet in
your apartment okay so that guy's out of
the out of the loop
but you can say well there are some
Farmers out there uh you know and there
are also people who
um uh you know have land
and they can produce something there
even if they don't produce it today they
can produce it in the future
and the question is why would they give
it to you
if it's the only thing keeping them
alive what do you give them give them
the money
and he said well I'm going to barter I'm
going to give him my car and my boat and
maybe maybe your wife or get rid of it
um it doesn't work that way because
after the collapse the only thing of
value is food
and there's no purpose in anyone trading
food for food
you just keep whatever food you have
and the only thing you need to do is
protect whatever food you have so if you
have a farm you're growing food well you
better be ready to protect that food and
how you're going to do that if you have
thousands of hungry people coming from
the city looking for food and they see
your farm with all that corn all that
wheat cows pigs chickens oh man it's
gonna be a Slaughter
and yeah I don't know if you can defend
that even if you kill half of them it
doesn't matter you know uh the point is
that all that food will be gone
so you know there won't be any bartering
any trading it doesn't matter what money
you create what medium of exchange you
create what currency you create so
currency is irrelevant
currency dies okay completely nobody
will accept money because the only thing
of value will be food just imagine a
hunter-gatherer out there uh Paleolithic
whatever
and he hunts a deer
okay so he kills a beer deer beer I I
have beer but he kills a deer and why
would he trade it to you what would you
give him an exchange
say well I've got pheasant or I don't
know I got eagle
I got a rabbit
you know it doesn't work that way the
hunter hunts whatever he's gonna eat he
doesn't trade what he ate what he hunted
especially if he's got a family
so this notion that you're gonna trade
something you're gonna say well I'm
getting I'm gonna give him my spear I'll
give him my machine gun for uh for the
deer
you just wait you I'll let you die and
then he'll take the machine gun from you
I mean he can go to the city and get all
the machine guns he wants after
everybody's dead
you get all the shoes he wants all the
clothes he wants
he doesn't need your machine gun or your
spear whatever you want to offer you the
only thing of value after the world
collapses the world economy collapses is
food and people have a trouble
understanding that because they say food
I can get in the supermarket yet today
not tomorrow okay that's the issue
okay fellow says Fiat money is a type of
currency that is not backed by a
commodity such as gold when fiat
currency gets to the point of a
wheelbarrow full of cash buys a loaf of
bread they just reset the currency it
happened over and over again yeah
because in the past uh we did this and
people think that again this is all
cyclical and history repeats itself
that's what they have in the back of
their minds
a global reset of the Fiat money system
is possible it's only belief of value
that allows fiat currency to function
yeah that's very important what he said
there's belief okay we won't be running
out of inches either okay
the value of currency is a barometer of
people's trust in the government if
there is no trust then you don't have
money
so he's got a contradiction he doesn't
believe that he doesn't understand this
he says we won't be running out of
inches yeah because interest does not
depend on faith
money does as he says here belief of
value okay if there is no trust you know
In God We Trust then you don't have
money
that's different in inches so it just is
a bad analogy for what's happening to
money
he continues he says the U.S retains its
currency's value by ensuring that a good
portion of World Financial contracts are
denominated in U.S dollars and he's
totally right there uh over 60 percent
of the world currency is U.S dollars and
so you know a lot of people do their
contracts especially International
contracts in dollars and a lot of
countries are now trying to switch away
from that because they feel the United
States is using that as a weapon against
them okay continue says no reason why
there should be any Global Currency
Reset coming anytime soon
okay yeah it's possible uh
um I don't think we need a world reset
like a global one but in fact today I
read that Argentina and Brazil are
trying to establish a currency between
them because again they're worried that
you know the dollar has too much of an
influence over their economy so they
want to do a local currency you know we
just discussed then we're gonna do a
local currency that just involves
Argentina and Brazil and of course if
that works uh they're probably going to
expand it to other countries such as
Paraguay Uruguay and other countries in
the region and that would push out the
dollar we have also the bricks over
there you know all these countries that
say they're going to be dealing with oil
in brics currency you have the Chinese
trying to put the Yuan push it you know
Russia is now agreed to accept the Yuan
and so little by little they're kind of
pushing the dollar out like saying you
know we don't want dollars but because
it's used as a weapon against us so I
think a lot of the contracts in the near
future at least will be changing and
it'll be done in other currencies which
is not the dollar we've got to see what
happens with that right
okay here one fellow says
I was thinking about post-humanism okay
AI you know artificial intelligence
technology becomes Advanced enough to
replicate human consciousness
I don't know okay let's assume let's
we're making this option here right if
Humanity gets to that point they should
leave a picture of how human
civilization was at least
yeah the uh I'm sure the the robots are
gonna worry about us once we're gone you
know they're gonna say oh these poor
humans they created us but they left and
so we're going to write the history
for whom
for the future generation of robots
you know I hope they have enough oil to
for their joints you know
the human wishes to be Eternal but it's
a fact we ain't
it's sad
well you know I like to say that what
God envies in man is his mortality can
you imagine living forever not being
able to die you shoot yourself in the
hand you stab yourself in the heart and
you don't die
that's that must be terrible it must be
worse than dying being able to die
now people say well you know I only got
80 years
that's so little
well if you compare yourself against
some insects They Live a month or two
months
uh you know they have very very
extremely short lifespans measured in
days and here we've been given you know
by Mother Nature 80 years 70 80 90 years
you know to live in general right that's
not bad we're among the animals because
we are animals that live a long time
you know maybe not the ones that we live
we probably don't live more than some of
the Turtles out there Galapagos turtles
or whatever but uh we live a long time
and so be be grateful that Mother Nature
has had pity on us or she smiled on us
and says I'm going to allow you people
to live 60 70 80 years you know that's
not bad considering you know what's out
there everybody would love to live 300
400 years maybe I don't know
it'd be nice but
don't don't complain so much 80 years is
not bad 70 80 years I live 70 so I'm
getting here there were there has to be
ways to hold human extinction back and
save up some time
um
you know I think again Mother Nature is
wiser than us she knows when to kill us
and one of the problems here is that you
know
um someone listen carefully here because
this this doesn't get into a lot of
people's brains I'm trying to get it in
there but people cannot relate to it
someone someone has to be the last human
on earth
some generation has to be the last
generation of humans on Earth
okay I hope that sank into somebody's
head out there someone has to be the
last human on earth some generation has
to be the last generation of humans on
Earth
turns out that you say I don't want to
be the last human on earth I don't want
to be the last generation of humans on
Earth that's so sad so you know I don't
want to be that person I don't want to
be in that generation
you don't get to choose
Mother Nature gets to choose he says
this is when everybody dies every human
dies whatever
and you say well I don't want to be part
of that generation
but look at it from another point of
view now
what you're saying is
I want my son my daughter to be the last
generation
now would you do that to your son to
your daughter do you love them that
little to say I want you to be the last
one I don't want to be the last one
that's terrible to have that thought or
great grandson or great grandson say I
want him to be the last one and not me
screw him
so uh by postponing all you're saying is
you want your granddaughter your
great-granddaughter or your even your
daughter your son whatever to die
in the LA as part of the last generation
not you
you know it used to be that the captain
sank with a ship and they had to take it
and you have to accept that and you're
saying no no I'm not going to die with
my ship I'm going to let the crew die
but I'm gonna try to save my buns
that's what you're saying so think about
that as well you know nobody wants to be
part of the last generation but we don't
get to choose it's Mother Nature that
gets to choose okay
and uh anyways uh keep that in mind
you know roll around your brain a little
bit okay so um because this is the
honest question is how much time do the
IU have on the clock
our bodies will not live to see the
extinction of man
well that depends you know I mean are we
talking about the Doom State clock
Doomsday Clock is the clock where you
know it's ticking because sometimes we
get close to throwing those nuclear
weapons
that's the Doomsday Clock and the other
option is what I had proposed is that
the eco-pyramid ecological pyramid
overturn
you know and so one of those two will
certainly guarantee our Extinction
now let's look at the Doomsday Clock
okay
um if someone throws the nuclear weapon
tomorrow here I've got it Illustrated
here we have three gangs
three uh gangsters three mafias
okay the United States Russia and China
these are the power Brokers today okay
so they decide to throw the weapons at
each other
you might say well they might throw only
one well what if they throw more than
one okay they throw more than one and a
we have a you know fireworks out there
right well yeah if they throw one I'm
sure that's not gonna stop there it's
probably gonna be the end of the world
not only because of the effect of the
bombs but because of
um
you know of what it causes to uh the
economy you know it's going to destroy
any economy irrespective of the Damage
Done by the bombs
so if if anyone throws a bomb I think
it's the end of the world if they decide
someone decides to press that red button
that's it
and lately you know they've been uh
talking about that
you know Russians have mentioned it
apparently a couple times that
they're not going to allow their
government to fall
before it falls
they might use that option of pressing
the red button
and if they press the red button
I'm not sure how anyone's going to stop
this
so how soon
can Humanity disappear can
um
are we the last generation is it that
soon will any of us see the last human
on earth or or be part of the last
generation of humans on Earth
well we can solve that very easily if
tomorrow someone presses the red button
we've only got weeks maybe months at
most to live
most of us and whatever's left will live
out their lives and that will be the end
of them
so yeah uh
the possibility is certainly there the
probability of that happening that's a
separate issue you know what are the
probabilities of those things occurring
Well everybody's got their own opinion
about that maybe these people are just
saber rattling to get to the negotiation
table and they want to have a good
position and negotiation negotiation
table and they're just going to go in
there and say look if you don't do this
I'm going to throw the bomb and so it's
just a thread but without any teeth
behind it
but if they do throw a bomb one bomb
just one
that's it
I think that's the end of it because
then I don't know why anyone would stop
okay I mean here you kill a hundred
thousand people with a bomb because you
threw it on a
you know some uh
military group out there
that's the end of it because they're not
gonna stop there they're just going to
be throwing bombs each way and then you
have also what the Russians said the
other day that you know they might adopt
the U.S uh government's
uh philosophy that maybe what they need
to do is a preemptive strike meaning
they would throw I don't know maybe half
their nuclear weapons all of a sudden
and destroy the other side before it can
throw its bombs to this side
so all these gangs you know they they do
all these things these mafias
you know they they might decide to press
those buttons if they do it's the end of
all of us it's the end of all of us not
because
uh we destroyed everything
it's not because you know that some
people have this idea that especially
military that a nuclear war is still
winnable
no it's not winnable because whatever
survives is not going to recover from
the economic collapse
it's the economic collapse that's going
to kill us all
the nuclear weapons just uh you know
like a preamble an introduction to the
collapse of humanity
and if a nuclear war doesn't uh occur we
still are facing economic collapse I
mean I'm not sure we anyone can avoid
that not a single politician or economic
Economist on Earth can avoid that fate
and so all I can tell you is that we're
doomed one way or another how much time
well this this is my crystal ball okay
that's the one I you know rub but um
that's about as close as it gets I can't
tell you for for a fact that it's
accurate I I use it for to drink mate my
the tea that we drink uh so no I cannot
tell you when it's gonna happen all I
can tell you it's gonna be soon whatever
soon means to you and when not if but
when it happens
if you happen to be around you're going
to be part of that last generation and
there's nothing you can do about it
okay
okay let's move on to our
um
subject for today which is
objective
is science objective what does
objectivity mean
and you'd be surprised the answer is I
got
anyways we start out with our science
critic because he
was the one who kind of introduced the
subject for us today and that is you
know I showed him a a little uh video in
which we have an astronaut falling to
Earth
and I told him the reason the cause the
mechanism right the reason the astronaut
Falls to Earth is that every atom in his
body is physically bound to every atom
on Earth
and I Illustrated it for him and I
explained
the mechanism he is watching
okay so not only did I illustrate it
listen carefully I Illustrated it and I
also explained what he was watching
you got that
this is what he said this is what he
answered so let's go with the with what
I showed him and how he answered it here
he goes give me a second
listen carefully
if I explain that an astronaut fell to
Earth because every atom in his body is
bound to every atom that comprises our
planet
all participants should be able to
explain the same mechanism in their own
words
that is not objective that is an idea
that you have come up with that could be
wrong and actually in all likelihood
that idea probably is wrong
so uh as well thinks that it's got
something to do with wrong and right
objectivity whether something is
objective seems to be related according
to him to what is wrong or right within
that wrong or right are opinions what is
wrong for you might be right for me or
vice versa
uh that seems to be subjective but in
his mind he thinks that is objective
okay so let's say what fingernails has
to say here he says the following or
this is essentially what he Saints in
objective what is it he says subjective
idea you came up with
so because I came up with an idea that's
subjective
makes no sense to me objective he thinks
it's an opinion you know right or wrong
if it's right if it's correct apparently
that's objective to him if it's a wrong
idea then it's subjective
this is the notion he's got in his mind
okay
and uh so you know uh we can summarize
because we can look at the definitions I
looked at the other day the ones that I
put up there and let's look at them
again to see what objective and
subjective mean and again these are
defined by dictionaries ordinary
dictionaries ordinary people who never
learn how to define words and so they
have 10 definitions for objective and 20
who are subjective
and so they have all these Notions and
people sometimes pick one notion the
other person picks on another notion and
so nobody knows what objective means or
subjective means why because there's so
many Notions of what objective and
subjective mean and therefore you know
people just pick up whatever go whatever
they're interested in whatever caught
their attention or whether it went
through their ears or their eyes okay so
here it is
uh objective you look it up it says not
influenced by personal feelings
interpretations or Prejudice based on
facts unbiased and objective opinion
dealing with things external to the Mind
rather than with thoughts or feelings as
a person or a book
belonging to the object of thought
rather than through the thinking subject
and existing independent of thought or
an observer as part of reality so we
have these different Notions that Define
what these people think is objective
subjective essentially is the opposite
okay
what do I say I say objective free of
interpretation clear cut we stop there
period you know free of interpretation
what a subjective belief and opinion
okay so I Define it concisely clearly I
hope
and people say well that's not clear bro
not to me okay so let's uh work on it
let's see if we can make it clearer okay
and what I show is a pulley that's what
I've showed last time we're going to
show up pulley here and it's gonna
uh have this rope tied around the pulley
okay and it's going to pull a box box up
very simple
so I ask the million dollar question
really it's a 10 cents question
how did the box come up
what
raise the Box
from the floor upwards
and what you're staring at what is
objectively in front of your eyes
is a rope that is moving and the Rope is
going up and it's tied to the box and
the Box comes up very simple here it is
okay what are you staring at what are
you watching this is the only question
what is in in your field of view
do you see any human do you see any uh
any machine do you see anything other
than a rope tied around a pulley tied to
a box and the box is moving up
apparently because
uh the Rope is being tugged from one end
by by something or someone that's what
you're seeing so we don't know what's
pulling on the rope but the pole or the
what the images are showing you is that
the Rope is pulling on the box
foreign
okay I think it's very straightforward
uh for kindergarteners some people have
a lot of problems with it they don't
understand why the box is being pulled
up and we're saying the Rope is pulling
on the box that's what you're seeing in
front of you this is an objective
explanation of the mechanism that pulled
the Box upwards okay
so I show them something else I show
good old Felix here and he's going to
throw something through a window
and I'm the theorist and I want to tell
you how the window broke
and I'm gonna say to you this is my
theory this is my explanation this is
the mechanism I propose and I'm going to
illustrate it for you so that you
understand it perfectly well without any
doubt that what went through the window
is a horseshoe a horseshoe broke the
window
now how difficult is that
well for some people it was incredibly
difficult they can't understand these
kindergarten things so here's my theory
of how the window broke I'm illustrating
it
and if you have a mental defect a mental
problem I explain it for you and tell
you in your face that what I am
proposing is that a horseshoe went
through the window here's the images
okay
here it goes
we have a horseshoe
go Felix winds it around throws it
now what did you just see let me show it
again because some people still have
problems here you have it one more time
okay just in case you missed it
horseshoe goes through a window
breaks it
okay that's my theory
now
people say well I don't know what
happened
now you just saw it I mean if you have
eyes I mean you're blind of course you
probably would not understand maybe you
would have trouble understanding okay
but what I just showed you is a
horseshoe going through a window and if
you did not understand that which is
kindergarten stuff I tell you so that
you can listen
that my theory that the explanation the
mechanism I'm proposing
is that a horseshoe broke the window
what did I just say a horseshoe broke
the window I Illustrated I explained it
and these people say I don't know how
the window broke
how you proposed that the window broke
that's at the issue okay how you what
your theory is Bill I don't understand
your theory okay so what does this fall
say he says there was a bullet that
broke the glass
[Laughter]
70 seconds before the magnet hit the
glass you are wrong because your eyes
are too slow to recognize the mechanism
I didn't see a bullet anywhere
but even if uh you know what this guy
says he says there's a bullet I'm
telling him what the theory is I'm
telling you what the mechanism I'm
saying it was a horseshoe that went
through the window and he said no it was
a bullet where did you see a bullet it's
not in the images
and I'm telling him that's not my theory
that it's not a bullet that I'm
proposing and this guy insists that it's
a bullet
so I don't know what he saw maybe he's
got special eyesight I don't know but
even if he's got great eyesight you know
Superman I said you can see these things
it's not my theory it's not the one that
I explained it's not the one that I
Illustrated and I'm explaining what he's
watching I'm saying it's a horseshoe and
he insists that it's a bullet
and then I asked him well how did the uh
pulley go up uh I mean the box go up
through the pulley you know where the
rope tied around the pulley and he says
run again Bill we are actually moving
down at the same rate as the pulley as
there is a motor inside the stationary
box pulling the pulley down towards
itself
where did he see this I mean he's I
don't know what these people have
through their tiny brains you know um
it's it's just an unbelievable
I showed him a box being pulled by a
rope that's tied around a pulley and he
comes up with all this nonsense where
did he see this and I'm telling him how
the Box went up I'm saying look the
reason the Box went up is because a rope
is pulling on it that's the mechanism
that's the theory that I'm proposing
and he's changing my theory he said no
bill that's not what you said there's a
machine there and blah blah blah
okay here we have another uh bird brain
says Fearless could be throwing the
Horseshoe while someone else smashed the
window
did you see anyone smash the window in
the pictures that I showed I thought it
was just a horseshoe going through a
window but he says there was someone
that smashed the window from the inside
right before the Horseshoe hit
I didn't see anyone I hope you did too
but anyways that's not my theory that's
not my mechanism that I'm proposing I'm
proposing that a horse you went through
the window you say no bill you're wrong
your theory is that someone broke it
from the inside before the Horseshoe hit
it
he's putting words in my mouth saying
this is your theory this is the one
you're proposing this is the mechanism
you proposed
uh so the window did not break because
the Horseshoe flew it you never know for
sure yeah I guess so with all these
mental cases you never know
okay how about the pulley and the Box
well he says uh oh there let me get it
went on the other side
it says something about a motor I think
he says the phone he says uh you're
wrong again Bill the mechanism that
pulls up the box seems to be someone
pulling the Rope
did you see someone
I mean I didn't show someone in the in
the movie that I showed and I'm telling
you that the Rope pulled on the box
because I'm just telling you that the
boat the boat the Rope is the one that
pulled the Box up I'm telling you this
I'm saying what the mechanism is
um explaining what you're observing what
you're watching and this guy says that
he saw someone pulling on the rope
I didn't see anyone well I don't know
but still that's not my mechanism
anyways but that's subjective it could
also be a motor inside the pulley
I don't know I I didn't see any motor
okay have you checked no I didn't check
because it's my theory see it's my
mechanism when I'm proposing science is
objective and I'm telling you what the
mechanism is so that you understand my
theory the mechanism I propose and I'm
showing a rope pulling on a box and
you're telling me that my theory that
the mechanism that I'm proposing is that
there's a motor inside the pulley
well I guess you know more than me you
know because I didn't show that but you
know if that's what you saw and that's
what you believe you know so since you
have ruled out this possibility from the
beginning of your assumptions or
your assumptions are only observation
based on interpretation based on
previous experiences so very subjective
so he thinks it's subjective because uh
what he saw was that something different
than what I explained and what I
Illustrated
unbelievable uh here's another fellow
and we had a lot of these fellows
they're they're all experts you know you
could wake up from a dream to see that
Felix never through the Horseshoe and
the window is not broken
uh I don't I don't know what he saw but
I saw you know what the movie showed
objectively because that's what we're
talking about here objectively what we
showed is a horseshoe going through the
window
and I explained that my theory my
mechanism when I propose is that a
Hershey went through the window and he
says the window never got broken
so maybe he slept through the moment
that the before she went through the
window I don't know he was sleeping
maybe he didn't see that
another fellow says he says so if
subjective is just a belief opinion then
objective is just a belief or opinion
so for him is the same he doesn't see
any difference between subjective and
objective it's all the same to him you
know it's no different to how you think
knowledge is just a stronger belief so
he thinks that objective and subjective
are both synonyms they're both belief
and opinion and I guess objective is
stronger
version of subjectivity I don't know
stronger opinion stronger belief do you
get the same meaning the presenter is
trying to Showcase do you get what he is
proposing yes or no
uh-huh well
you know the the issue here is that we
stare at something
we look at something
you know here here let me give you an
example what do you see there you see a
rope that's what I'm showing
okay this is objective
I'm showing a rope
and this person comes and says now you
showed
a uh a uh what is it a uh unicorn
no that's not what I showed I showed you
a rope but he said no you showed me a
unicorn
and I'm telling him look this is a rope
and he said no it's a unicorn
so either he's got problems with his
eyes or he's got a problem with
understanding because I'm showing him
something I'm telling him what he's
looking at just in case he missed it and
he still says it's something else
so he says I I interpret it I believe
you have something else
this is the problem okay
what you watch is objective what the
screen shows in your face had better be
objective and everybody who has eyes in
the universe had better see the same
thing
what comes out of a screen is always
objective
and if in addition
I explain what I'm trying to portray
there what I'm trying to illustrate
there
you should have no problem reaching the
same conclusion we should all have the
same interpretation there should be only
one interpretation
for sure I cannot lie to myself and say
you know this is a road and then I say
well by the way that wasn't a rope
now it's either a rope it or it ain't
can't be both
you know I can maybe lie to you but I
can't lie to myself
hopefully if I show you a rope and think
it's a rope and that's I'm gonna give
you my explanation based on a rope
you know I better at least be sure of
what I'm showing you
okay and then it comes to you if you
interpret something other than a rope
that I'm showing you well then you got a
mental problem you got to see uh you
know psychiatrists shrink
okay uh I think the same fellow last
time he said uh his objective is in its
agreed upon meaning
no it's got nothing to do with meaning
it's got nothing to do with the green
and science we do not agree
I don't know where these people have
their tiny minds they're they're flying
around you know
my God
another fellow that's what I like he
says subjected to 22 plus minutes in the
most in in the moot Court of words
these feel these people think it's all
semantics it's all word Wizardry word
salad it goes through one ear and comes
out the other for them they say hey I
didn't understand any of that I came
here to do physics not Grammar I think
I'm here to do to learn you know how to
make sentences and definitions came here
to do physics
and you'll see where where this leads is
it is that physics yeah it's physics uh
what you call semantics word salad
that's 150 physics if you do not Define
your terms you're talking nonsense as
you will see very clearly that this
individual talks absolute nonsense
you'll see it in a second should Bill be
our objective Authority has nothing to
do with authority has to do with what
you just saw on the screen
you know if you see the Mona Lisa you
say that's the Mona Lisa that's a
picture of a woman
and if you say well now that's not a
picture of a woman that's a snake
well then you got a problem either with
your eyes or with your understanding
okay
he says the cartoon describes the
mechanism but only my theory is
objective
no no it's not that my theory is
objective I'm trying to explain to you
my theory what's objective is what I'm
showing you on the screen and I'm
explaining I'm describing or whatever
what's on the screen
so that you understand my theory
so that we're all in the same page
and if you don't understand the theory I
go one further step and try to explain
in more detail until you do understand
my theory my theory not your theory we
don't care about your theory right now
I'm the presenter I'm the one who's
showing you the movie of my theory I'm
explaining to you my theory and you're
saying you don't understand it
or you say that oh that's you're you're
you're an authority no I'm not saying
it's an authority I'm giving you my
version of how the universe works that's
not an authority because Authority has
to do with belief I'm not asking you to
believe it I'm asking you to understand
it
these mental cases they don't understand
any of us okay it just goes through one
ear and again because they think it's
word Wizardry
uh even without an explanation of the
theory or mechanism and again he thinks
it's a question about 30 and I don't
know what's going through their tiny
brains
okay so
um but let's go through what his this
fellow proposes he proposes dielectric
he says this is the solution to all
these problems you know and so he says
the answer is magnetism and it's
consubstantial dielectric Force
and I'm going to digress for a second
here just take a little tangent just to
address this because it shows why these
uh mental cases because that's what this
person is he's a mental case these
people they use words that they do not
understand and one of them is dielectric
of course the other one is magnetism
they think these are physical objects so
they're going to explain their Theory
using magnetism using dielectric they
say oh the dielectric moved in this
direction moved up and down they do
everything with them without electric
they use this word dielectric for it's a
mystical word
and so here it is this is how uh what
dielectric is we look it up and here it
is what are dielectrics dielectrics are
materials that don't allow what current
to flow
what does current flow mean it means
that they are saying that the electrons
are moving from atom to atom as you see
there on the right it's Illustrated okay
they are more often called insulators
because they are the exact opposite of
conductors but usually when people call
insulators dielectrics it's because they
want to draw attention to a special
property shared by all insulators
polarizability okay
so they're talking about polarizing they
have positive and a negative that's all
they understand there you see it on the
battery a positive and a negative and
you see the little electron bead
bouncing around okay and they call this
nonsense dielectric and that's what
they're going to do their Theory with
they're going to do a current flow and
of course they cannot explain what
they're they cannot describe really what
their atom looks like
what is the atom is it a little proton
in the center with a little electron
bead moving from atom to atom is that
what electricity is current flow
it says when the when a battery is
connected to a conductor the potential
difference whatever that is right of the
two poles of the battery pushes on what
on all the charges how do you pull it
push a charge if a charge is 1.6 times
10 to the minus 19 coulomb in other
words charge is a number it's a quantity
and they're going to push a quantity and
this Val is you know he's got these
brainwashing uh since he was a kid and
he doesn't understand any of this how do
you push a charge in physics we're not
talking about math here we're talking
about physics so he's going to push a
charge in the conductor he's going to
push a number in a conductor great which
in turn causes them to what to drift
slowly through the material creating a
what a current through the conductor so
they're going to have this current which
is a word that we use for Rivers you
know like the current and they're going
to have this current flow and what is
this current flow it's the push of
charges okay they call this whole thing
dielectrics okay electrons Wander can
wander freely that's what current is
according to the establishment this is
what this person learned by heart okay
he just memorized it so he uses the word
dielectric it says in a dielectric the
electrons are stuck inside atoms and so
current doesn't flow at all so what is
an electron it's a little bead that is
stuck inside the atom and for some
reason sometimes it flows which we don't
know why what pushes it out of the atom
or pulls it out right and so current
doesn't flow at all so these people have
this notion that that you see there at
the bottom where the electricity is just
a flow of electron beads from one
planetary atom to another that's their
notion and from this they get this word
called dielectrics and that's what
they're going to do there uh you call it
physics they're going to do their
physical interpretations with this
nonsense the electric field okay field
what is a field exerts a force a field a
concept and exerts a force it pushes a
wall that's great for fields to push on
on a wall right and it's going to exert
a force on what under charges so here we
have a field exerting a push or pull on
a number oh great you know this is what
they call dielectrics all this nonsense
the individual electrons remain tied to
their parent atoms the electrons remain
leashed to atoms by what the
electrostatic forces so we have uh this
call this thing called the force
whatever that thing is I've never seen a
force I guess it looks like uh tether
whatever and and it's leashed it leashes
the electrons to the atoms
so with all this nonsense of course this
person says you know
um uh bill we can explain all this with
dielectrics okay and uh
and so you know this is how they do
their so-called physics they use words
such as force field wave ether plasma
and dielectrics and they come they think
of themselves as intelligent first let
alone the fact that they think of
themselves as physicists they think they
know how this universe works and they're
using all these Concepts as physical
objects
so yeah we do need to Define these terms
to find out what they mean and this
person never came to you know to figure
out never analyze what he's talking
about he's just using these words oh the
dielectric
but then he says I do word salad right
yeah
okay so here's the summary by one fella
who I think did a pretty good job
because he synthesized and I think
understood it quite well so here it is
he says you want to define something
referring to the universal movie right
called a static concept so you simply
Define a thing called a frame as a
result of a universal pause button
we pause the button right so that we can
see the objects before we move them
around
okay we look at the static concept and
we look at the object we want to see
what's in a single frame before we move
anything around you can't put dielectric
in a single frame and of course people
like this fellow doesn't understand that
it's beyond his capability so yeah we
have a horseshoe there okay that's what
I have to show you first I showed you
the Horseshoe so you say look this is a
horseshoe okay now you've seen the
Horseshoe now I said look this is the uh
mechanism that I propose for how the
window broke and that's the Horseshoe
went through the window
now how complicated is that
okay and again we have all these people
who say no no it was a motor it was who
knows they come up with all this
nonsense so so if I show you a horseshoe
you're not going to say well what he
showed is a unicorn or he showed
Superman that's what went through the
window or it was a rock
no I'm showing you a horseshoe and I'm
telling you in your face that it's a
horseshoe that you're staring at what's
your problem what is it that you don't
understand
that's objective when what you see what
the screen shows you is objective now if
you have trouble with seeing then you
have a problem with your eyesight and in
your understanding you are subjective
not the screen
the screen you know it just pushes out
stuff into your eyes and that stuff
should be the same for everyone in the
universe any Klingon who comes and
watches the movie should see the same
thing as you do that's called objective
what comes out of the screen
if you did not understand the mechanism
that you just watched
the theorist comes in and clarifies for
you look this is what you just watched
so if you're missing something in there
you know I clarify and fill in the blank
so that you understand completely what
my theory is
and after watching and I explain to you
what you're watching you still say well
no Bill said that Superman went through
the window
or someone broke the window before the
horse you did
okay so this is where the problem is
with all these people okay
so here we have it uh yeah this is the
universal movie and in any frame all you
have is location you have distance
between all matter and the first thing
we do at least within a frame is Define
the uh static Concepts that you see at
the top those are the most important
ones in physics to give a physical
interpretation to any phenomenon and we
have the word object we have that's all
we have objects we call it matter the
the uh
whole set of objects out there we call
it matter the ones that exist okay we
have between the objects separation we
call it distance we have the set of
distances for any given object we call
that location that is the location for
that object with respect to all other
atoms or all other objects in the
universe that's the only thing mother
nature and father Universe understand
location they don't know how many meters
they don't know how many feet they don't
know how many kilometers or miles all
they know is that this uh atom or this
object is separated from that object
that's all they know
okay and then we have existence whatever
exists is only in a single frame all the
other uh Notions such as you know there
you see any of them at the bottom motion
plasma ether and so on dielectric we
should put in there so that these people
don't commit such gross errors oh those
are Dynamic Concepts and we can't get to
them until we understand the static ones
first all Dynamic Concepts are built
upon static Concepts you need to Define
absolutely need to define static
Concepts before you can move on to
Dynamic ones because Dynamic ones are
founded or are defined in terms of
static Concepts
okay so here let me give you an example
of why we have problems with all these
people who do not understand what
objectivity is
this is Mr Einstein and he proposes
something that you see on the screen
let's get this right okay you're going
to watch something on the screen
and that should be objective everybody
should see the same thing because I mean
if you want I'll I'll show it to you a
hundred times until you see the same
thing as everybody else
so we're all going to watch something
and we're all going to see the same
thing that's objective because we all
saw the same thing not because we
interpreted the same thing but because
what the screen showed us is the same
for everyone
let's get that right that's objective
and if you did not understand what you
just watched it wasn't clear to you then
Einstein comes in and he's going to
explain what you just watched
so you have no excuse not to understand
after watching and having the theorist
Einstein in this case tell you what you
watched
you have no reason not to understand it
especially if it's a simple concept A
simple mechanism right A Simple Theory
so here it is this is Einstein he's
going to explain to you general
relativity how gravity works here it is
okay all for you okay Einstein says look
there's a net a fishnet
we can call it a canvas if you want no
problem
you have this fishnet and we have a ball
rolling around it
do you see anything else on the screen
other nights then obviously do you see
anything else on the screen what do you
see what is objectively there in front
of your eyes
well hopefully you see some kind of fish
net or something looks like a a net of
some kind right and you see a ball
rolling around
okay that's what's in front of you now
if you see something up you see Superman
if you see a unicorn I can't help you I
mean you have problems that you got to
see enough domologists
okay but what's in front of you is a
ball rolling around a net that's what
you see there okay so now Einstein
explains look what you're staring at is
the earth rolling around space time
okay so far so good he's saying look
that net represents uh space-time and
the ball is the earth and the reason the
earth goes around is that something is
either pushing or pulling under net
downwards and then the ball in this case
the Earth is pushing against the sides
of the net and it doesn't get away out
of the solar system obviously right
that's that's the idea that's the
explanation for why the earth goes
around the Sun
okay so it's very clear
uh something pushes or pulls the net
downwards and the ball the Earth does
not fly out because it's rolling around
it's pushing against
or being pulled I guess from the outside
uh is pushing against or pulled out
towards the net it cannot Escape that
circular motion
okay that's the theory that's the
explanation that's the physical
interpretation of Relativity for gravity
okay now what is the problem with this
the problem with this is that this is
not objective
it's not objective not because the image
is wrong the image is no problem we all
understand the image it's not objective
because Einstein is telling you that
what you're staring at is not a net
it's space time it's a concept he's
saying that time is Warped he's saying
that what you're staring at is not a net
but warped time
well I got a problem with that see I got
a big problem with that because that's
not what I'm staring at what I'm staring
at is a net I'm not staring at Warped
time
okay so this is where the problem is
there is any consistency inconsistency
between what Einstein has Illustrated
and what he is explaining that you are
observing
so he's cheating on you he's lying to
you he's misleading you he's saying look
what you're staring at is not at a net
which is exactly what I'm staring at
he's saying what you're staring at is
what time
so there's an inconsistency this is not
a a an objective Theory it's in uh it's
not even it's you could say it's
subjective in other words the the
subjective explanation does not match
the objective
images that we see on the screen
there's a
disconnect there
that's the issue so the theory is not
objective it's not a scientific theory
because all scientific theories physical
theories physical interpretations
mechanism they have to be objective
what you see is what you get
you cannot say this is what I saw but
this guy says well what you saw is
something else no no don't tell me that
I have my own eyes to tell me what I saw
okay so don't tell me what I saw I
already know what I saw just you can
fill in the blanks if I miss something
but don't tell me I'm watching time or
time but I watched what I saw is a net a
fishnet a canvas maybe whatever
okay so I I hope you understand what
what the issue is here what what the
difference is okay
and of course uh what they do in general
relativity is say well uh you know uh
the famous cartoon where they say uh
understanding gravity space time right
is like a rubber sheath like they're
going to use an analogy right
massive objects what distort the sheet
and
and so the student says hold it they
distorted it because they're pulled down
by what
good question what is what physical
object is pulling it down and her
teacher says oh my God no this is simple
is it space time is like this set of
equations
but that's not what you Illustrated you
did not illustrate an equation you
Illustrated a net or a canvas
or a trampoline and you put a bowling
ball on it that's what you Illustrated
but now you're saying that's an equation
now I got a problem with that that's not
an equation that's not even an analogy
for what you showed on the screen
okay so this is the problem the problem
is that the explanation the descriptions
they don't match what they're showing
there's a disconnect there so it's not
an objective Theory because what's being
explained or described does not match
what is coming to your eyes there's a
disconnect a complete disconnect there
here's another example famous very
famous famous experiment
um example
and here you see it uh particle can be
at two places at once according to
quantum mechanics and there you see it
so what are you staring at well I'm
staring at two particles that's what my
eyes show me I see two particles
and they say what you're staring at is
one particle of two places
well no that's not what I'm seeing I'm
seeing two particles
and so they want to make you believe
something they they cannot illustrate
they cannot even illustrate and that is
a particle being at two places at once
two different places at once they cannot
illustrate it because what you will see
always is two particles
that's not what they're describing
that's not what they're explaining
so there's a disconnect between what you
see and what they're telling you in your
ears the the site does not match the ear
the hearing
that's where the problem is and that
they don't match
and of course then you have people like
uh Juanito here Juanito Baez and he
professor of one of these universities
says 10 points he wrote this in his
crackpot index he says 10 points for
arguing that well a current
well-established theory predicts
phenomena uh correctly it doesn't
explain why they occur or fails to
provide a mechanism
yeah because what happens is that so he
takes 10 points off of you or gives you
10 points for being a crackpot right and
yeah they cannot explain the mechanism
because if they what they show does not
match
what they're explaining there's a
disconnect a complete disconnect there
and this is the the issue the issue is
that their explanations don't match what
you're seeing now here comes Bill gatie
and he comes up with something different
and he's the uh he shows the following
and he says look uh what you're staring
at is two balls
those are atoms they look like balls in
real life
and they're expanding and Contracting
and by doing so they torque a rope-like
entity twine pair of threads that
physically
find them
and those torsions is what we call light
now you cannot say this is not objective
because what I just explained is what
you're watching what you're staring at
I'm not saying look what you're saying
is what you're looking at is an equation
okay uh you're looking at a unicorn no
no I'm telling you what you're staring
at I'm just saying look we have two
atoms they're expanding and Contracting
doing their Quantum jump as it's called
they're bound or connected by a
rope-like dna-like entity and when they
expand they torch the rope and torsion
is light uh this light is torsion along
that rope a propagation of of this
signal
so what I'm explaining is what you're
observing now we have a complete
connection between the explanation and
what you're staring at that's an
objective Theory
okay this is not subjective like the
other people which says well what you
stared at is not what we Illustrated
we Illustrated this but we explained
something else
yeah you did not watch you did not watch
a or or see a uh a fishnet what you saw
as an equation
no no no no no I I saw I feel that's
what I objectively saw
and now they're saying well but you're
supposed to make believe
you know go through the motions of
believing that that's an equation
this is the problem with uh what the
mathematicians do that's why what we
have today out there is not objective
theories and therefore if it's not
objective it's not part of science
science is
150 objective objective means that you
have an image coming to your eyes
and hopefully you understand it just by
watching the images but if that's not
enough the theorist comes in and
clarifies for you what it is you're
staring so that you understand exactly
what he proposes everyone in the
universe should understand what the
presenter is is proposing
now you might have a different Theory
you might say well I have a different
Theory no problem we don't care about
your theory we're caring about right now
about the theory being presented by the
preceptor by the person who's giving the
presentation
okay so that has to be objective if you
know there can only be one
interpretation
for what the theorist is proposing there
can't be ten different interpretation
for what one theorist is proposing
especially for a mechanism mechanism has
to be straightforward otherwise the
machine doesn't work uh uh my son says
that in programming you have to program
it right because you know you can't
cheat whatever you tell the machine to
do that's what it will do because it
follows a certain logic you cannot have
10 different interpretations 10
different channels for the for the same
for one mechanism otherwise you know the
computer doesn't understand it'll follow
whatever you told it to do
so it's kind of like uh forcing the
logic everybody has to understand the
same thing
and people have trouble understanding
that they think that uh objectivity
means that uh I've got a different
opinion I've got a different way of
doing this it's got nothing to do with
that at all it's got to do with
what you watched what images were shown
in your face and if that was an
objective enough because you did not
understand it because you don't have the
capability of understanding what they
just showed you on the screen the
theorist comes in and clarifies anything
that you need to understand so that you
understand his theory the mechanism he
has proposing
that's called objective science had
better be objective and all mechanisms
especially mechanos they have to be
objective they can't be anything other
and that's what physics is about
explaining mechanisms
you have to explain how Mother Nature
runs her shop
okay so we got that
okay so let's look at some of the common
questions some people man here's uh one
fellow he says
tell us how a 3D one piece extended
object can bend without interfering with
itself
very simple it is referring to the
single thread okay
and we say that the single thread is
made of a single piece okay uh it's 3D
okay 3D made of a single piece it's
malleable
and it's intangible
so it cannot touch itself it goes right
through each itself
so I don't know what this fella wants to
know I mean right now we have to explain
how you know light goes through light
without touching itself without getting
tangled or or bouncing you know if it's
particles why the particles don't bounce
out
even though some people out there claim
they have made photons pop out of there
they call them virtual photons obviously
they don't do it with real photons so
it's nonsense what they allegedly proved
no you have light go right through light
doesn't get tangled you know it's like
you put two shower caps uh showers I
mean you know and you have the water
coming out or you take two hoses with
water coming out and you can go you know
just have the water uh sprays there go
through each other but they hit each
other and some of the drops bounce away
that's not what happens with light
so what you have to explain is Mother
Nature's world not the one you want
it's the one she has the one we have to
imitate her world and her world is
intangible unseeable also okay uh and
we're saying it's mediated by a single
thread which makes all the atoms and
ropes that interconnect them in the
universe it's made of a single piece
it's malleable and it's 3D
and so people say well you know I don't
know of any object that is made of a
single piece that is malleable well the
first thing is that you don't know of
any animal uh object that is made out of
a single piece no such a thing in our
macro world
all objects are made of atoms so they're
all made of parts and here we're saying
the single thread is not made of parts
and then they say uh well I cannot
imagine something that is not that is
not made of parse
being malleable
because our notion is that we think of a
steel beam and we say well steel beam is
like it's made out of a single piece and
it's so rigid you can't bend it
and so they have this notion that if
there's a single thread out there it's
made out of a single piece it must be
rigid
that's a wrong assumption or you can
make that assumption I make a different
assumption I make assumption that this
thread has all the uh properties that we
see in our macro world and that is it
acts like a river in the sense that it's
malleable like water you know it's made
out of a single piece we don't have an
example of that in our world at all and
um
and it builds everything else in the
universe and so since it it's intangible
you it doesn't have the property of
tangibility it can go right through each
other without any problem he said
doesn't he cut it because may not have a
single piece why would it
what would be the cause of that we have
to explain Mother Nature's universe and
Mother Nature's universe is that light
goes through light that's her Universe
you gotta explain that you gotta
simulate that not what you want to
simulate
it's the other way around you got to
simulate her Universe not the one you
want
people don't always catch on to that you
can't
imitate all the properties of Mother
Nature's Universe of whatever she uses
out there with the properties of our
macro world not everything can be
extrapolated to her world in great
measure because we know her a world is
different than ours
obviously it's different than ours
because we cannot see or touch the
mediator of gravity
and see so how can how come I can't
touch the mediator of gravity because
it's intangible that's why
the mediator is intangible and people
choose instead to say well there's
nothing there
well if there's nothing there you're
doing gravity with black magic hopefully
there's something there that you cannot
see or touch that's a more rational
explanation or or assumption for what
you're what for this phenomenon called
gravity
okay another fellow says
how about qualitative ideas of time
change then not mathematical
quantitative there are imperceptible
periods of change
he's referring here to uh the notion
that you have I said you have one
location of an object right here so here
we have an object it's here
and now the next location is over here
and he says Ah but there had to be
motion
for it to change location
this is the issue okay do we need look
to for to move from one location to the
other do we need motion
okay this is the issue we say move we
move from here to there so uh we change
location only because of motion okay is
this true
well obviously not because we have to
define the static Concepts before we
Define the Dynamic Concepts so we have
to Define what location is before we can
Define motion because motion is two or
more locations but the fellow says oh
but to move from one or or to change
locations to occupy for an object to
occupy two locations it's got to move
this is this is what is going through
his mind
but see the issue is you have to Define
location before you Define motion you
can't use the word motion to Define
location and if you're going to say that
to occupy two locations you need motion
we still haven't gotten the word motion
we're not there yet
first we have to Define location so here
it is okay
here we have just distances between
here's this a static concept here we
have only distance everything has just
location what is location the set of
distances very simple okay so nothing's
moving there it's a single frame of the
universal movie we have three objects
and they're separated the lines indicate
distance okay separation that's all we
have so far
okay I hope that's not too difficult for
some of you people okay that's all we
have we have dislocation of the blue the
green and the red with respect to each
other we have distance and location
that's all we have there in front of us
so far so good okay now we're going to
move them
okay in other words they're going to
change locations now we're going to have
motion because we're going to have two
locations
and this role is essentially saying oh
but you had to move
in order to get to the second location
okay this is what this is the notion
he's got
and I'm saying I'm gonna move them very
little I'm gonna change locations on
them you know they're just going to have
two different locations in fact more
than uh two here you have them okay they
moved okay so now we have motion but
what is motion motion is two locations
or more
and so he says yeah but to move from the
first location to the second location
there had to be motion
no you can't have motion because motion
is defined as two locations now if you
want the locations I made them as close
as possible I can make them even closer
if you want
okay so if we have the universal movie
and we have location here and in the
next frame we have another location
which is right next to it almost
you can make it the distance as much as
as short as you want
you want to make it shorter make it
shorter
but we don't have motion until we have
two locations of an object
and people say but you had to move to
get to the second location no you you
don't because it's the other way around
motion is two locations
okay and so if if the the object
occupied the next location
gazillionth of uh
uh distance separation you already have
motion
motion comes after location you can't
say you had to move to get to the new
location no it's the other way around
two locations makes motion okay so uh
motion is constructed by locations not
the other way around okay all we have is
distance
okay we have separation whatever
okay and so here's the universal movie
okay again you have to define the static
Concepts before you define the dynamic
ones you can't Define motion until
you've defined distance and location you
need distance and location first you
cannot say that if it occupied a
different location we had motion in
between it's the other way around motion
is defined as two locations or more and
you can make those distances as short as
you want as brief as you want no problem
but hopefully in the Universal movie A
gazillionth of uh whatever you know just
tiny tiny difference in um in location
that makes motion it's a different frame
of the universal movie
and I don't know if that sunk in some of
these people's minds okay here we have a
first of her fellow he says there's no
physics without math
well you need to Define physics in order
to say that until you Define physics we
uh don't don't understand why we need
math okay we Define physics as
um explanations of mechanisms and causes
and for that we need no math whatsoever
okay
and then he says Uh there's nothing
wrong with copying and pasting the
correct physics definition of object aha
well it's easy to copy but harder to
defend
you got to defend your definitions and
hopefully you can't use arguments such
as tradition that's how we always did it
uh you can't use democracy we all voted
for it you can't use Authority this is
what the mathematician told me to say
none of that you can't you you have to
be able to defend your definitions so
you can copy whatever you want but if
you cannot defend your definition you
know your copying was worthless you you
wasted your time
okay let's see what another fellow says
here he says
[Music]
um
you can say objects are that which has
shape in the same breath called space an
object you can't say I'm sorry you can't
say objects are that which has shape and
in the same breath uh say space is an
object
uh okay this is the issue the issue is
the the word he's referring to the word
Universe essentially here he's saying
that
um you know uh I Define universe as
object objects plural matter right plus
space space and matter both together
form the word Universe okay that's what
we call Universe matter and space but
what happens uh a concept such as the
word universe
is uh either two objects or an a concept
which is treated
momentarily as an object okay so it's
not that uh
space has shape it's that we treat it as
an object as if it had shape because we
have two things one is matter or objects
and the other one is space
so we call that the union of these two
as universe
and you know I want to be honest with
you uh I had trouble with this in my
book because I did put objects Concepts
and then I put space as a separate
think thingy like a separate category
why because you know we look at the Moon
and the Earth and we say well what's
that black stuff
so it's a different kind of concept than
love for example you know when you have
love uh you can't picture it
intelligence you can't picture it uh
Grace you can't make a picture of it
okay but space is a special kind of
concept you know nothing
because it's got color this that black
color between the Earth and the moon or
be or between the Stars so it's like
it's a special kind of concept this
notion this nothingness
and so it's it's it is misleading and
that's why so many people throughout the
ages turn treated spaces of physical
object and they think we're enclosed in
some kind of balloon or whatever and
space is this balloon that is maybe
finite others say it's infinite whatever
they mean by that okay and so we treat
it as a physical object
and I kind of made that same error
because I said well we have Concepts we
have object and we have space
okay and I've corrected that since then
uh you know space is a concept it's a
it's a synonym of nothing nothing is a
concept okay and it's a contrast with
objects
okay so it's an antonym of object okay
and yeah all I can tell you is that
space is just another concept it's it's
a synonym of nothing
there is no thing out there called space
but for the word Universe we treat it as
if as if it were an object so we have
two thingies we have matter and space
the comparison or the relation there is
what we call universe so universe is a
concept now if Ella out here says the
following he says uh you can't live in a
concept no kidding you're right totally
right you can't live in a concept an
abstract idea that only resides in the
mind or minds of mankind right you can't
live in a concept the universe certainly
isn't a concept
oh why isn't it does the concept expand
so he's got you know uh relativity has
this uh balloon expanding balloon
analogy for space-time and so they treat
space itself as a physical object they
say space is expanding or space-time is
expanding or whatever okay time expands
and space expands nothing expands you
know because space is nothing and so
yeah
um he's right in the sense that
uh Concepts don't expand and we cannot
live inside a concept
okay and we don't we don't live in space
because to live in or inside space space
would have to be a container of some
kind with some surface with some edges
then you can say you live within space
like you live within a container within
a box then you could say you live in or
within but we cannot say that we live in
space because again that's uh ordinary
speech an ordinary speech you can get
away with anything but not in physics in
physics we cannot say that we live in
space
okay
and again the only way you can live in
space is if space had borders if space
is a container then you can say I live
in space or within space okay you can't
say that in physics because space is not
a physical object
therefore you know you cannot say you're
within these surfaces Within These
borders
you know this is the issue and then uh
then the other issue is that you know
all you can say is that you have
location with respect to the other
matter in the universe and you can
select anyone that you want you can say
you have a location with respect to the
sun Jupiter the moon whatever you want
to use as a reference
but you cannot say that you live
a certain location with respect to space
because space does not have borders does
not have surface does not have a wall
there where space stops and you can say
well I I have a certain distance with
respect to space meaning the edge of
space meaning the wall of space the
surface of space you cannot say that
okay space is nothing nothing is that
which has no shape meaning it has no
borders you cannot escape space that
doesn't mean you're within space because
space is not an ocean that has you know
a finite surface or a finite extent
so you do not live within space like you
live like a fish lives within an ocean
okay you can say a fish lives within an
ocean because you know the ocean has a
certain uh border surface which ends
where land begins you cannot say that
about space so you cannot say you live
within space not in science not in
physics in ordinary speech you can say
whatever you want people confuse
ordinary speech with science that's
where the problem is okay here's another
felony he says a double slit experiment
is very easy to explain or should I say
debunk aha good for 200 years they have
never been interested in seeing these
supposed waves and wave interferences
between the slits and the screen okay
after 200 years of mathematical Faith
someone actually decided to make the
right the light visible through a cloud
chamber they made the light visible I
See the Light okay
surprise surprise no waves are seen
okay so they made it visible they don't
see ways what did they see he says only
independent what raise
of light never interfering with each
other they saw a rays
just like high pressure water coming out
of a nozzle at jet yeah unfortunately
rays
right and jet
are not physical objects
you so we cannot see that which is a
concept and Rey is a concept but this
file doesn't understand that because
again all that's word solid for them
they they don't understand and for them
as they say oh that's just you know
semantics
that's why you need to Define these
terms because you cannot say that they
saw rays
you haven't said anything you can't see
a concept you cannot see a field you
cannot see or touch a field for that
matter you cannot touch or see Concepts
you cannot hear them either
okay
so whenever they say they saw a ray or a
jet
is not a physical object unless you're
talking about an airplane you know a jet
that's okay but if you think that a
spray of water is a jet that's the the a
jet is a dynamic concept so his array
but these poor fellows you know they
they don't understand that
they're not Savvy enough they don't have
the mental capacity to understand what
I'm saying to them it just go through
one ear and not the other okay here's my
phone he says they'll ask he said what
is your personal stance on the concept
of death and the concept of me
okay that
um is a little different than alive or
living
alive and living you do not have to
reference it to something else death you
have to
death implies that the thing was living
okay living does not imply that you came
back from the dead Okay so there's a
difference between alive and living as
compared to death death is a process a
phase that we discussed in the past
there's a phase there death implies it
was living now it's going through this
process we which we call death might be
a second of a gazillionth of a second
whatever it is and now it's dead okay so
they're not exactly alike but death but
if uh alive and living means that which
moves Against Gravity primarily or
against the path uh the path of least
resistance death is the opposite it
cannot move against gravity essentially
that's what dead means it's inert okay
but again keep in mind that death
implies that it was alive living does
not imply the opposite it's not an
antonym in that sense and regarding me
we have two Notions we have one which is
the body some people refer to me as the
body but most people like to think of me
as what you have in your mind
your thoughts your you know what they
call the spirit right all this all these
words we created throughout history and
so people say yeah me is what I think
what I what I am is up here not not this
that on the outside that you see
this outside is objective that's me the
objective me okay and what's in my mind
is the subjective me and I don't even
think God knows what I have in my mind
so uh just keep in mind separate those
two because some people turn to me
called The Mind into the soul the spirit
and they end up sending it to Heaven you
know that's where when we run into
trouble that's when you know you need
another beer to get out of that mode
Paul says light speed cannot get
multiplied as Albert suggested thus E
equals m c squared is irrational
yeah in mathematics you can multiply
numbers times numbers and that's what
they did you know when they say 300 000
kilometers per second square right which
is the velocity of light squared
mathematically you can do it physically
what does it mean that's a separate
issue now okay and you can't say I'm
going to multiply you know rope times
rope or torsion times torsion
that's physics and you can't multiply
those things because they have nothing
to do with math and that's why math has
nothing to do with physics physics we
have to explain the mechanism
and so we we say what does MC well the c
squared what does c squared mean
and it means that
one atom sends light to all atoms in the
universe and all atoms in the universe
send light back to it
it actually is simultaneously because
what's happening is the Rope is just
truly in place in situ and so the the
signal really goes both ways and that's
what light squared means in physical
terms but he's saying you know you can't
multiply light times light meaning
velocity of light times velocity of
light meaning 300 000 kilometers per
second times 300 000 kilometers per
second yeah you can do it mathematically
whatever that means we don't care
because that doesn't concern physics at
all physics we don't care about
multiplying
physics we just care what is the
mechanism that's what physics is about
okay here we have fellow says Jesus
Christ is a human with a physical form
okay the gut of the Old Testament and
New Testament are the same a physical
person I guess he's referring to Jesus
being God right
uh God here on Earth
uh New Testament doesn't contradict the
Old Testament in the least
well it does I mean if you ever read the
Bible like I did I mean I read the Bible
three times one of my favorite books
love it absolutely love them it's a
great book very historical book that's
why I like it so much Old Testament says
God hears God sees God walks and what
part says the burning bush the Flaming
bush
so those are all objects I mean if God
can hear and God can see and God can
walk he's a physical object so he's
right if he says the god of the uh Old
Testament is the as a physical person
that we understand the problem is with
the New Testament where it says God is
love and God is Spirit
well that's great poetry
but if that's literal then we have a
problem because love and spirit are
Concepts
so the religious person who proposes his
theory of God or whatever uh what God
did how he created the universe or
whatever he's going to explain he's got
a first define whether God is an object
or a concept if God is love and God is
Spirit Concepts God could not you know
got love cannot have created the
universe a spirit cannot create the
universe
so the proponent has to decide whether
God is an object or a concept I can only
tell you that the Old Testament says God
is a physical person like Jesus Christ
human life in fact God says uh if he
wrote the Bible right uh that he created
us in His image
I guess that's as clear as possible God
looks like us like humans
and so where did the New Testament where
they changed their religion
where did they get the idea that God
suddenly is not a physical person but
God is this concept Called Love or
spirit
there's a contradiction there and it may
be great poetry I don't have a problem
with that you know but then we cannot
take that literally so the proponent has
to tell us whether God is love or God is
a human
and you might say Bill you're
exaggerating you're taking this to
extremes no I'm not let me tell you
though that we had
um one of these pastors out there you
know an Indian fellow in fact who said
God is intelligence
well in terms if God is intelligence God
is not a physical object so you got to
tell me whether God looks like us made
in our image or we were made in His
image and it's a he not a she make sure
that and don't tell my wife obviously
you know
um but if God is a human or has a human
form then you cannot say God is
intelligence
if God is in towns and God Is Not a
Human God is a human's not intelligence
it's one or the other and if you're
using poetry we don't care for it we
need in physics we need to know whether
God is an object or a concept you got to
be straightforward
and so you can't cheat in ordinary
speech you can do whatever poetry you
want you know no problem
s uh asked the question uh a short while
ago he says he's got an object or a
concept and again addressing the same
issue and here it is
uh we get this out of the Old Testament
you know and again what are you
objectively seeing here
are you seeing
something it looks pinkish you know kind
of
it looks like like a human that's what
what I see objectively in front of us if
that's God God is an object it's a thing
you know he
that looks like a human is a thing we're
things
we're not Concepts
but uh uh and uh you know in the Old
Testament also you have this
here you have uh God is a plant
apparently because it says uh it's uh
the Lord appeared unto him in a flame of
fire out of what the midst of a bush and
he looked and behold the bush burned
with fire and the Bush was not consumed
okay and there you see the illustration
What are you staring at what is
objectively in front of your eyes well
you see a burning bush
now if uh the Lord was the Flaming Bush
or he was hidden inside I don't know
that's not very clear uh whether he's a
synonym of the Bush or or he was just
hiding in there that part I cannot tell
you but if God is a bush or God is the
guy on the left there which looks like a
human pointing with his finger well yeah
you know then God is an object and if
instead you know if God is uh what the
New Testament says you know love uh
spirit or like some of these pastors say
God is intelligence then God is concept
so it's up to the uh presenter the one
who is going to propose God as part of
his theory part of his explanation of
how the universe came to be or why the
flowers are so perfect or whatever
and he's got to tell you whether God is
a concept or an object and that's where
his religion dies because whatever he
chooses he's got to be in trouble that's
all I can tell you why because if he's
an object if God is an object
then we can talk about God's existence
he's a concept if God is a concept we
cannot talk about existence the only
objects can be said to exist in science
and physics in a rational way
if God is an object if he wants to exist
he's got to also have location meaning
he's got to have distance with respect
to me his chest has to have a separation
with my chest
then he then God exists he exists by
definition not because I believe or stop
believing in him okay so it's very
simple God has to be an object in order
to exist and that's not enough he needs
also location
and if God is a concept it doesn't exist
by definition
we'll see you next week